foreign
how do you know when it's time to stop
trying for another baby and going
through recurrent losses and kind of
move forward with life oh gosh let's
don't solve that one that was really
hard
it's a big one for a Monday yeah
[Music]
yo yo yo what's up this is John with Dr
John deloney's show
show about mental health marriage
relationships parenting
the madness that is our education system
whatever you got going on in your world
this show here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna walk alongside you and I don't
have every answer but usually I know the
people who do or I'll tell you I don't
know
but I also promise I'm gonna walk
alongside you and I've got two decades
of walking with people trying to figure
this stuff out your mental health your
marriage whatever is going on in your
life if you want to be on the show give
me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 and we gotta start
Today's Show with probably some of the
most important news we've ever discussed
on this on on the air ever
Jenna
yes this week in Nashville there was a
storm of Epic Proportion and the storm
was named hurricane Taylor Swift yes
what in the world insane yeah I heard
500 000 additional people were downtown
yeah for various other things that were
here this weekend but yeah it was insane
I went to two of the shows two of the
three shows I went Friday and Saturday
it was mass chaos downtown but it was
the most fun I've ever had in my life
how many homeless people could you have
fed with the ticket prices okay we'll
talk about that okay so so you're on the
floor the first night the second night
yeah second second night I got to be on
the floor nine rows from this stage and
see her and all her it was amazing it
was just she was an ethereal Queen on
stage it was it was wonderful
I mean
I I want to say what I think but man
swifties they will come they will come
find you in your sleep listen she puts
on a show her production I heard it was
I heard it was Second To None three and
a half hours of just non-stop just fun
did she do the same set Yes except she's
got a portion in each show where it's
two different song it's like an acoustic
set two different songs every night okay
um and Friday night she it was it was
amazing I was up high but she announced
so she has like her re-recordings that
she's doing and she announced to the
entire stadium that she uh is releasing
the speak now Taylor's version in July
and she was like I'm gonna surprise you
guys right now I've been planning this
for months and the entire stadium was
just I can't even imagine how loud it
was if you were standing outside I heard
there were shrieking the sound of
shrieking women cascaded through the
hills of Tennessee like in a way that
like
people's roofs were coming off and their
sidewalks were buckling that it was
intense what was your favorite song of
the night uh well so Friday night she
did like the surprise set and the first
song that she did was Sparks Fly it's
from speak now it's one of my favorites
of all time
um but other than that there's on the
Evermore album she performs champagne
problems it is fantastic did you ever
weep uh I got very close I got very
close especially that she sings a song
and the set called Marjorie it's about
her grandma who passed when she was 13.
I don't know how she performs that song
every night because it's just
gut-wrenching but my favorite things in
the whole world is how you talk about
her
I've been like
the like church services that people
have less reverence for God than how you
were discussing Taylor Swift right now
it's incredible like you I can feel you
through the booth man it's amazing
listen this has been a this has been a
thing for about 15 years of my life so
so do you feel at peace now can you move
on can you go to like Metallica no I
will I'll never move on from that from
this weekend oh gross all right let's go
out to Tom in Los Angeles and get some
some soul back in the show
all right hey I am jumping in here this
is future John
this is John from the future after this
show has already been recorded
and I have to come back and say this
next call you're about to hear
I missed it and here's what I missed
okay so you're gonna listen to this call
and you're gonna hear me and you're
gonna be hollering at your phone or your
your speaker in your car or in your
headphones when you're mowing the yard
but however you consume the show
watching YouTube You're gonna be like oh
my gosh huh I know I know I know
here's a couple of things number one I'm
pretty sure
after listing this call
that this man's wife
is a significant challenge it's a
problem okay also
I try my best I'm not always perfect but
I try my best to not bad-mouth
somebody's spouse
when they're not on the phone
that's hard right the third thing is
most of the time when you're dealing
with somebody who's got a spouse and the
spouse is just out to lunch the spouse
is just spending money willy-nilly this
boss is cheating on the spouse is
struggling with addiction whatever
you as the person on the phone the
person who's calling and saying how can
I help my spouse how can I fix this I'm
lonely how do I do these things can't do
anything about the spouse
only person you can change is you
and so you're going to notice in this
call I don't think I messed this part up
I intentionally focused on this guy what
can you do
why is your wife creating a world that
you don't exist in
I think the reality is she's always had
that life
she's always spent money she's always
run up debt she's always creative
alternative life that she is living that
this guy is funding
but that's not always helpful for me to
just Grenade on somebody
so you're gonna hear this call and
you're going to be going what do you
mean it's completely her I'm I'm with
you I'm with you and
I really want those of us the folks who
listen to this show who are struggling
with a spouse struggling with a friend
struggling with a mother-in-law
struggling with whoever
to go back to the one place
where transformation happens and that's
in the mirror
that's with you
asking yourself what are my thoughts
what are my actions what can I control
here
so check out the call be nice in the
YouTube comments be nice
here we go
what's up Tom
hey how you doing John I was doing great
until Jenna started talking about the
Swift shows but I think you're gonna get
us back on track man well I feel I know
you deal with life and death stuff and
heavy marriage hanging on the thread
stuff and I feel a little bit silly for
this call but
yeah so here's what's going on I travel
a lot for work about four days every
other week and my wife loves to travel
for fun and this month especially she's
gone a lot and
um I'm not included on those trips it's
girls and it's this and it's that and
I'm feeling a little bit excluded and
the other part of that is when I bring
up
um like hey most of my travel is an hour
or two flight from our house and I say
hey why don't you come out for a night
or you know take Friday off we'll spend
the weekend there whatever wherever I am
and it's quickly dismissed and it's like
hey I need more time to plan and this
and that and and if she wanted to do it
there would be a plan B like if one of
her friends calls and says hey let's go
here for the weekend you know she'll
find a way to make it work and so I'm
I'm calling you and thanks for taking my
call because I feel like I'm getting
wound up in my head and I don't want to
be resentful I want her to enjoy the
trips I want her to be I love her
because she loves to live her life and
have fun and there's also a little bit
of a back story if you don't mind when
we got married we had a lot of debt and
her dad was travel debt and we did FPU
and we paid it off and we've been debt
free ever since
um a year and a half ago I was
refinancing our house shortening the
term and lowering the rate and she had
hidden a bunch of debt as well and so we
downloaded to every dollar app and paid
that off ahead of schedule
um did you all deal with the infidelity
uh a little bit so no not really not
really and that really and the other the
other and and we're both men here the
other trigger is I I was a single dad my
kids spent every other weekend when I
traveled with her mom and I would
constantly get emails from her like hey
check out this Cruise it's on sale or
this or that and I would be trying to
make ends meet and you know and so
there's these little triggers along the
way that when she's like hands on you
know to Hawaii or I'm doing this and and
works good money's good she does well I
do well we're working our butts off but
there's all these
things along the way that are just you
know when she's when she says Hey I'm
going here in two weeks with my friends
for three days and I'm getting back from
my trip with an empty house and you know
and there's all these little things and
I feel like I'm getting wound up in my
head and I don't want to
um be that guy who's resentful or treats
her poorly or you know
where it's changing my everyday life and
I feel like I'm turning getting to that
point and well you're like your everyday
life has been changed and I I would be
willing to bet
um I don't have a nice car but I'd be
willing to bet it
um
that this is just a symptom of a bigger
issue because she's created an
alternative life that doesn't include
you for whatever reason
whether you hold her accountable whether
you're not safe whether you always have
some scheme or plan or whether your
rules and your whatever always trumps
she's created a world or you're an
anxious mess
um are you a high strung guy are you
anxious a lot
um I do pretty well with that I'm not
but I will say you know and I know you
travel for work and and I'm raised by a
single mom and not a close family and so
I can be a lonely guy and kind of line
that up as well and so you know coming
home to an empty house after being on
the road and yeah but that that's that's
not the issue the issue here is you all
y'all are co-managers of your household
you aren't doing this thing together
right
right and travels but one thing that
y'all do separately
right and we'll do trips together but
it's been a while and that's kind of the
other I know but you're not hearing what
I'm saying dude you're not hearing what
I'm saying your marriage is running in
parallel you have two people living
under the same house that are sharing
the same name that have two completely
different lives
right and this travel this her going out
of town with her friends her world that
she has curated that doesn't include you
that's but a symptom
of a marriage it's running on a on two
side-by-side tracks but it's not working
together
right and you can't control why she has
created a world
what you can control is why she has
excluded you from it
right right
and so if I ask you because she's not on
the phone if I ask you why does she
choose why won't she travel with you why
does she not like traveling with you
I can answer you I can answer this from
my house
my wife doesn't like to travel with me
because I don't care about itineraries
because I just show up whenever I hate
getting to an airport more than an hour
like I like to get to the airport just
in time to get through TSA just to get
through and walk straight onto the plane
while they're boarding for her she wants
to be there seven to ten days before the
flight actually leaves she likes to
spend the night in the airport I'm just
kidding but she likes to be there so
early and then when we get to wherever
we're going I don't know we'll find a
hotel when we get to the town like
that's how I roll and that makes her un
feel unsafe
right and uncared for so that's why she
doesn't like to travel with me why does
your wife exclude you from Joy
yeah I don't know we we went to Cabo in
January you know you know
yeah I don't you know it's hard I I'm
the last couple of vacations and I've
asked her about it have been good
you know but our our sleep schedule is
different you know I'm older I don't
like to party like I used to but we
still the last I and I looked at it the
last couple times we vacationed and we
had a lot of fun I know but you keep
focusing on vacation
yeah
yeah I don't know there is a bigger
issue here man
maybe I you know I don't know maybe
because I watched the pennies
um maybe because I'm jaded because I
travel for work and it's hard to impress
me I don't you know
the question you've got to ask your wife
is and really yourself is beyond travel
you're stuck on this travel thing
um
when it comes to how the house feels
when you get home and she's there how
the house feels when she gets home and
you're there
to how y'all handle conflict to what
y'all like to how do you like to honor
each other by
um how the other person likes
entertainment and I'm gonna show up
there your sex and intimacy life I'm
telling you right now something's off
yeah
and you keep focusing on this travel
travel travel I'd be willing to bet if I
talk to her it would have nothing to do
with travel
is your way of escaping getting away
right living the life that she doesn't
feel like she can live at home
right
and it could be that she's a brat and
again I'm not talking I don't talk about
your wife but it could be that you would
like to have a budget and you don't like
to spend money y'all don't have and
she's like I gotta live like that YOLO
whatever that could be it she could be
very immature
or you could be so constricting and hard
to live with
that she's had to create an alternative
world
when I was an anxious mess
I was always seeing the end of time I
was always dealing with
okay we're gonna move our money here and
this scheme here and then we're gonna do
this and then
I I remember sitting down in my backyard
in West Texas with my wife and I said
you I feel like you've created a world
that I don't live in
she said I've had to
and those words were one of the impetus
for me to go get go get help
right
because I was I was a nuclear reactor I
was kind I wasn't abusive I didn't cheat
but man I was electrified and that's
just me I don't know what your thing is
you might be the opposite you might be e
or bring the whole house to I don't know
but your wife has created another planet
that you don't live on and she doesn't
want you living on it she'll go with you
on your rocket ship trips to Cabo cool
that's fine right I think she likes you
yeah but there's something bigger going
on man
right
that's very interesting I haven't looked
at it like that and um yeah that's
interesting I appreciate that so here's
here's if I'm you
here's what I would the way I would
start
I would take her out somewhere nice
and I would say hey I want to talk about
us
and I would say I've been asking about
travel and I not she doesn't make you
hurt she doesn't hurt your feelings
you're allowing your feelings to be
heard okay I'm gonna use that language
this is all about me
I've decided to get my feelings hurt
whenever you're gone and when you create
these travel plans without me and when
you don't want to go on my work trips
and but then I started thinking
are there other places in our
relationship where I'm not showing up
where we are running parallel lives
and I want to create a future where I
can help meet your needs and you feel
empowered to help meet my needs and
we're working together on this deal and
it becomes much less about will you do
this thing and go on this trip and why
can't I go it's it's a much richer
experience
I'll tell you this
when my wife is about I've mentioned on
the show um it's probably four or five
months ago when I was struggling with
with my daughter who's had was six at
the time and she's turned seven since
um
and between my wife and Dr mate Gabor
mate
really hammered home what if I
concentrated on being likable
not on always being right not on always
lecturing not on always trying to solve
every problem or have my opinion heard
on everything but
what if I focused on being likable being
fun being funny
um staying up a little too late
sometimes getting up a little too early
sometimes
like
spraying one of the kids with a hose
when they get home allowing them to
spray me back when when I'm least
expected whatever the thing is
what if I just did the dishes instead of
making it like checklist about it
and I tell you what man my whole house
has changed
marriage has changed my relationship
with my daughter my son have changed
everything is different now
because I'm working hard not to be right
not to win not to make sure every tea is
crossed and every eye is dotted but
to be likable
to be a joyful person and it's just
ricocheted through my life so sit down
with your wife and talk about the state
of your your marriage let her speak and
don't try to correct her
this isn't something you're going to
solve in one meeting
but ask her
my hard to be around am I hard to travel
with
if you had to create another alternative
World alternative universe that I'm not
a part of because I'm tough to be around
start that way let her speak and let her
be open with you it might be a really
hard season coming up but man if you get
to get through this and get to the other
side of it y'all can create something
amazing we are in Tandem and you're
working together
and then you can take all the vacations
you want man
but you gotta heal from the inside out
on this one we'll be right back
[Music]
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling hallow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hallow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right we are back let's go out to
Beth in chai town in Chicago what's up
Beth
hello how are you partying how are you
good awesome what's up
thanks for taking my call
um my question is how to let go of the
anger with my father and I'll give you a
little backstory
we haven't had a relationship in decades
like he was invited to my wedding didn't
show up
um butted meters first granddaughter
when she was born didn't come and so
after that I mean I wrote a letter to
him didn't send it but just to get all
my emotions out
and felt like I really had peace about
it because I didn't understand how he
couldn't be there for me and my siblings
even his brother and his mother but
after I had a child it really changed my
perspective on all all of it and I
thought I really have mental illness
you know my siblings and I think we have
diagnosed him you know just in our heads
but we don't know
I would be willing to bet
um a lot that he was struggling with
something pretty profound
the act of walking away from your kids
and your grandkids is so unnatural
yes
and I hate that you experience that
thank you
but you know that's not your fault right
no
and I I'd always said or I said in the
letter that I wrote to him and said you
know the only way I can have any sort of
respect for him of being my father is
just not to know him at all because I
can't understand
how we could do that
um and really
over the past year he gotten really sick
and you know I struggled with we all did
with should we go visit him
um and then ultimately will we go to his
funeral and
we weren't given the opportunity to we
had to find out he was sick through
multiple different parties and
um
so he was remarried his wife had just a
quick burial the obituary wasn't
released until after the funeral
and we weren't even listed anywhere in
it
um
and then since then you know I went back
and looked at the tribute wall on his
obituary and every single person on
their comments about how he was you know
the most dedicated Christian man that
they knew
um
and I'm like he abandoned his entire
family
and I I don't know I have a lot of anger
towards that I thought I had peace about
everything else but now I'm just angry
one of the hardest fantasies in the
world to let go of is a is the parent
walking away from their child
one of the hardest ones in the world and
you can think you've dealt with it and
Buried buried it until they pass away
and then there's that your body realizes
oh this never this never wraps up
there's no there's no
happy ending
yeah and as much as it's frustrating you
you know we've seen enough Hollywood
movies where you know
the kid walks in and Dad's on his
deathbed and he says I'm proud of you
you know what I mean like and yeah that
will never happen
so my question for you is this and it's
a hard one okay
what is this anger getting you
why are you still at war with him
I don't know I think it's just having
children and not being able to
comprehend how I would do that and you
can't you can't you know you can't make
rational sense of an irrational Act
I would tell you any any energy you
spend trying to make sense of it is a
waste of time
it's energy you're taking away from your
kids and dumping into a bottomless pit
you can never wrap your head around it
because it makes no sense
and I know that's maddening
yes
but there's there's this idea of making
peace with my dad walked away from us
forever
and I would let people have their story
about them
because that gives them peace the ones
that he chose to be in a relationship
that weren't you
let them have their story
I mean what senses of it is to burn that
to the ground
like you could show up at his own at his
old church and be like hey I'm his
daughter he walked away from and he
never met his grandkids because he
sucked he was the worst guy ever just
wanted y'all to know
my promise is you won't sleep one ounce
Deeper by doing that
yes because I didn't think about that
and of course I stopped myself but yeah
you know how good that would feel it
would feel amazing it would feel so good
the retribution it would feel good for
like five seconds
you know what I mean and on the way home
you'd stop it like a burger joint and
eat yourself into a coma because it
would feel so good
and then you go home and then you'd
realize you went with you
nothing's changed he still walked away
from his little girl
yeah most of the time people get stuck
here it's for two reasons one
its rage anger feels good
it does
the fantasy of what I'm gonna do or what
I could do feels so good
and the second thing is is there's some
sort of lingering dot dot dot that I had
something to do with this
and your body Loops trying to solve what
was it about me that he walked away from
because I can I need to solve that so it
never happens again
and both of those things are unsolvable
Loops they will spin faster and faster
until you become an anxious mess
and then in a strange way you restart
the cycle and your kids want to stay a
few inches away further away from Mom
because she's a lot
is that fair
yeah I mean the cycle starts again
so whenever I someone's facing this that
you've done part of the work okay I
always direct people to write four
different letters
all right
you've written one of them was it the
vomit letter
that you suck and I hate you letter okay
when did you write that
uh when my daughter was born 18 years
ago okay let's update that one okay yeah
so here's what we're gonna do we're
going to write a letter to let them know
what you really think Dear Dad
you suck
you left your daughter you left your
granddaughter you left your sons you
lost them all
you created this little fantasy world
that your little fantasy church and you
played
super Christian
while your family wondered why dad left
write that letter
in the second letter which is really
hard to write
is a letter that lets him know what you
miss about him
here's what I missed
and the first letter is usually angry
the second letter is really sad
because you might have some memories of
him when you were really really young
where he was funny or sillier took you
fish in or did something goofy or
whatever you can remember his aftershave
whatever the thing is or he would kiss
you and it would it would gristle your
face with his whiskers whatever the
memories you've got locked away in there
here's what I miss
then the third letter
and all these have probably a week or
two weeks between them okay because
they're heavy
the third week is the the third letter
is the one of empowerment
here's what you're gonna miss
your granddaughter is freaking amazing
and because you chose to walk away you
will never know how awesome she is
here's some awesome things she's doing
you're a son-in-law he's the best father
you could ever imagine on and on okay
what we're doing here is we're creating
movement the other way
you're teaching your body by going
through this process that season is over
he's gone
and here's what comes next
then that fourth letter
why did he leave when did he go
he
um
like he was a great dad when we were
really little
um my mom and him got divorced when I
was 16. okay my my siblings were already
moved out of the house and graduated
and
really we just didn't have much of a
relationship I mean years before he left
why did they get divorced
he was cheating on her with his wife
that he had
okay
so my guess is
um
whether you remember it or not from
about 13 14 and 15 you lived through
hell in that house is that fair
oh absolutely yeah
so your fourth letter is you need to
write
Beth
14 15 16 year old Bethel letter and let
her know this was not her fault
she's still trying to defend you
Fair
yes
she still runs the show a lot
when you got really really pissed when
you were 15 or 16 what did you do did
you did you withdraw did you throw and
kick did you yell and scream what did
you do like just full like angst as a
teenager
I yelled at him I took it all out my
siblings were more reserved and when
they hurt their fit when he hurt their
feelings they didn't say anything and I
was always the one
to defend them or me or my mom or any
anybody on how he just wasn't there how
often do you yell now as an adult
oh I have my moments she's still
protecting you
yeah you gotta let her go
when those adult when when we as
grown-ups have those moments of of
childishness
when I ignore when I stamp my literally
I'll stamp my feet and ignore my wife or
my kids or my workmates
that is me being nine all over again
right
that's that little boy coming up being
like oh we'll show them
and it's like no dude you don't get to
drive because you're nine right
similarly
you gotta let that girl go and that's
letter number four
okay
I've also heard folks with some pretty
significant
um success in and you've heard me say
this if you've ever listened to the show
more than a couple of episodes is to go
to the Home Depot or Lowe's or something
and buy a cinder block
yes and put duct tape on it and write
your dad's name and write the day the
last day you remember talking to him
in person
or write on that thing you died and
wouldn't even let us come to the funeral
and carry that sucker around your
backyard carry it around your house
until your arms burn look till it gets
so heavy
and then take it as far in the far
corner of your of your backyard or a
park or wherever you find peace
and set that sucker down and rip the
tape off and and in that moment commit
to never picking that brick up again
I'm not carrying my dad's
trauma anymore
I'm not carrying his hatred I'm not
carrying the fact that he walked out on
his little girl and her brothers I'm not
carrying any of this stuff anymore
he doesn't get any more from me
and you're gonna wake up certain days
and you're going to find yourself
carrying that brick and it's fine you're
just gonna have to remind yourself I'm
not carrying that anymore you're going
to find yourself start to scream or yell
at one of your somebody you love and
you're gonna stop yourself mid-yell and
be like I'm not carrying that anymore
I already let Beth uh Beth little Beth
go she gets to go play
she used to go finally be 16 like she
should have been a long time ago
but it's going to be a practice I'm not
carrying anymore I'm not carrying this
anymore I'm not carrying it anymore he
gets no more of me
because he's had enough of you for the
last however many years
and we're done
now it's time to live forward does it
suck that he abandon you God Almighty I
can think of hardly anything worse
is it unbelievable that they hid his
funeral from you didn't even mention you
in the obituary yeah
it's wrong it's wrong at every level and
it happened
those four letters are grief
it's a practice of grief it's a practice
of sitting in it and it hurts and it's
probably best if you have somebody you
can read those letters to maybe your
brothers will join you in this exercise
and you can read your letters out loud
to each other
grief demands a witness you do this
stuff with other people
and if you're really Brave you read that
letter out loud to somebody or to a
couple of people that you write to your
younger self
[Music]
we never carry the brick again
so much for the call Beth we'll be right
back
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back and
therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself to help you set boundaries and
still have energy left to help others
without leaving yourself behind so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's totally online to
fit into your schedule you just fill out
a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge so find more balance
find Wellness with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloni today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back let's go out to
Hope in Durango Colorado
that's not even a place Colorado what's
up hope I don't even know where that
accent came from what's up how are you
good how are you I I mean
I'm just having the time in my life
running a scam here called a podcast
what are you up to
just working taking a break to talk to
you awesome so let's solve this problem
what's up yes so my question is how do
you know when it's time to
stop trying for another baby and going
through recurrent losses and kind of
move forward with life oh gosh let's
don't solve that one that was really
hard
it's a big one for a Monday yeah
um gosh
oh man um
so how many losses
um so our story
um my husband and I've been married for
almost five years
we got pregnant the first time a month
after we got married
and uh lost that pregnancy about a month
later and then found out that there was
actually a second baby in that pregnancy
that was in my fallopian tube it
ruptured and I came pretty close to
dying before I had emergency surgery yep
um we got pregnant two more times that
year lost both of those and then uh
fourth pregnancy seemed like it was
going in the right direction finally and
then I got the same debilitating pain
and sure enough it was another ruptured
ectopic had my second tube removed in
emergency surgery
um we
are Big Dave Ramsey followers so we
saved up in cash flow to do IVF because
that was our only option to for me to
carry our baby at that point
um did IVF our first transfer Embryo
transfer was perfect our embryo split
into identical twin boys and they are
wonderful they're two and a half now
yeah two for one there and then we
decided to start trying for baby number
three in January transferred again that
embryo also split and would have been
identical twin girls but we lost them
and then just last month we were gonna
try one more time to do a transfer and
hope that it would work and like a few
days before my
um scans just weren't looking very good
and so it got canceled and
but I felt like I had had a lot of time
to like recover from the previous losses
but going through these last two cycles
just really put me back in that really
difficult space and I just don't know if
it's time to move forward and just enjoy
the boys that we have
or what
so I want to preface this with this is a
deeply deeply personal
um decision okay
yeah
um this is a decision between you and
your husband this is a decision about
identity and a decision about there's so
many different decisions here okay
um
I want to talk to you broadly and then
we'll get very specific okay and I'm not
going to sugarcoat anything and I need
you to know if we were having this
conversation in person I would go a lot
slower than I'm gonna go today okay
okay is that fair
yeah okay
I'm really worried about
your marriage
this is a lot of loss
in a very short amount of time
yeah and I it's statistically speaking
the ice y'all are on is so thin
um
you you know exactly what I'm talking
about don't you
yes yeah we came very close to not
making it to even have our boys because
it was so hard that first year yeah
the challenge is grief um as the great
David Kessler says is like a fingerprint
it's Unique to everybody and when you go
through loss like this especially
miscarriage it's hard to discuss in it's
hard to even know right because it feels
a certain way and there's there's
hormones but then there's also loss and
then people feel it differently and
think differently about it
and you've got one of you saying well
I'm ready to try again you've got the
other person like I can't breathe you
what are you talking about what's the
matter with you and it's when you get to
the what's the matter with you or what
do you mean we're just gonna stop and
just sit here for a year so you start
grieving separately
and when you start grieving separately
you create two different worlds right
and then somebody at work is a little
bit funnier a little bit nicer or a
little bit we can talk about something
else and then all sudden you're down
hatch number one or down hatch number
two so just starting broadly for the
sake of your marriage I would tell you
to take a break
yeah
just need to Exhale for a season
um
and y'all haven't even had a chance to
be married yet y'all got thrown right
into the middle of a
scorcher right
yeah for sure
um
how old are you
I'm 31. okay why this it almost feels
manic why why the
push push push push go go go go go go
definitely felt that
that wanted to be a mom I've always
wanted to have a huge family and I think
manic probably is a good term for how I
felt um like just as soon as one loss
was over it was time to try for the next
one and how did y'all how'd y'all grieve
the loss of those um pregnancies
everybody does it different so there's
not a right or wrong way
boy I
um I'm really open about it so I've
shared a lot about it with just friends
and family and everybody yeah you're
sharing the process
how did you greet those individual
losses
I we moved forward really quickly I have
the name of every one of the pregnancies
that me and my wife have lost which are
three tattooed on my body
oh wow okay and it's not for everybody
but
there's something profound about
stopping
and acknowledging loss
even if you aren't that like man it
wasn't a baby yet whatever wherever you
fall on that Spectrum which is a whole
other conversation
the moment you find out your pregnancy
a dream is cast out ahead of you right
oh yeah you start making plans
and you start building rooms and you
start
um
you start imagining and it's really hard
to just let that thing dissipate and go
you have to honor that man a path just
laid out in front of us and that path is
over
you know what I mean
some people do it by writing letters
to the the baby that they lost some
people write poetry some people call
some friends over and have a formal
Funeral Service some people come over
and and say hey
we won't acknowledge this together this
is a heavy season for us we lost this
but just blowing by it and blowing by it
and blowing by it seven times that's a
lot that your body's carrying for you
yeah definitely
have you been open with your
um husband about the nature of these
losses
yeah yeah we're very open with each
other about all of them okay
you're calling for a reason are you
calling because you want permission to
stop
or do you want permission to keep going
I
I think it's permission to stop
okay I need you to hear me say and I'm
gonna speak for everybody in humanity no
one can give you that permission that's
for you
but you have my permission to stop
and you're gonna have to grieve that
dream that you're gonna have 14 kids
running around
and all their knuckle-headed girlfriends
and boyfriends and party you're gonna
have to grieve that
and just because you grieve that picture
doesn't mean you don't love recklessly
these two knuckleheaded twin boys you
got
it's both and
but I think it's worthy of writing
yourself
your future self a letter
the 52 year old you that was gonna have
six kids running around
and honor her
because man we just just listening to
your story y'all went down swinging
right
yeah
but it's almost scary to reimagine your
marriage right now isn't it
yeah we just feel like I've never had
time to do anything fun like we're
taking a family vacation at the end of
this month and that's like we never even
had a honeymoon like we just hope it is
not you are not going on vacation you've
heard that old saying if it's just you
and your spouse that's vacation if you
go with your kids it's a trip you're
going on a trip at the end of this month
with two twin two and a half year old
boys there is going to be pee and poo
flying airware foreign
diapers and naps and shenanigans and you
sitting and reading a book in the
bathroom of a hotel like that that's
just gonna be what this trip is
but you can also find deep resounding
joy in this little four this little gang
of four That's Just Gonna Take On The
World
yeah
re-imagine place I guess when you were
expecting it to be different it is
it's hard it's devastating
yeah I think it's hard to not have like
and I almost wanted like a second chance
at pregnancy because theirs was just so
terrifying because of all the losses
before and so I was like this next
pregnancy I'm gonna do all these things
differently and then I hope so
none of this loss was your fault
I remember sitting with the woman one
time who looked up at me through through
tear-soaked eyes and she said the
following I'm tired of my body killing
babies
yeah
and I just hugged her and I didn't say
another word because there wasn't
anything else to say
and what I should have told her was
not your fault
because you have spent the last five
years
trying to reverse engineer every step
you took and every meal you had and
every bout of gas and diarrhea and
everywhere you've tried to reverse
engineer at all
it's not your fault
okay
yeah Hope's not broken and hope didn't
do anything wrong
is that fair
yeah okay
the scariest question you and your
husband have to answer
is not are we gonna have any more
the scariest question you'll have to
answer is
what are we gonna do now
and who are we gonna be now
yeah
and the beautiful thing is you all get
to choose
are we going to forgive each other
for how we did or didn't respond
are we going to
work really hard to alter our mindset
towards being comically overly grateful
for these two Rascals we got
and Our Gang of four
and are we going to properly sit and
grief for what wasn't
right you have to walk through all that
stuff
yeah
you just can't avoid it
but I would definitely take a break how
many
um embryos do you have out
we have six more
[Laughter]
that's incredible you're gonna have a
hundred and a lot of kids hope yeah we
had five boy embryos and three girl
embryos and we were like boy if they
split every time that's a lot of kids
oh the hope jeez
I mean there's going all in
like I'm going all in and you put your
car keys on the table and your house
deed on the table
I can't make those calls for you okay
that's between you and your husband but
I would definitely recommend taking a
break for for a while
yeah okay and you know this when you get
to be 34 35 they start telling you that
you're a thousand years old
yeah and that you're this Grandma trying
to have a baby which is just stupid
okay
yeah you got time
if time is even something you want to go
down that road
but what you'll have to do right now is
spend some time healing your marriage
healing yourself you gotta grieve these
losses that's a lot of loss
you gotta grieve your body that in your
heart and mind failed you
but you also got to make peace with it
because that's the only one you got
yeah
yeah you got to make peace you gotta
grieve that future we're gonna have that
we're probably not gonna have it's gonna
look very different and it's still gonna
be awesome it's just gonna be different
kind of Awesome
Fair
yes
I'm really grateful that you called
thank you thanks for your time
hang on the line here I'm going to send
you a copy of on your past change your
future actually I'm gonna send you two
one for you and one for your husband and
it really is the path
here's where you go when all the wheels
fall off and all the plans we had going
this way suddenly here there's that road
implodes and what do we do now
so hang on the line here I'm going to
send you a couple of copies of that
um
and you call anytime I can help you with
the grieving process very happy anyway
I've been down this road um
personally so
um
thanks for being brave
to do everything new
we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
um Kelly is so old that her favorite
show Growing Up was Alf and she got to
listen to this song live
not live but like you were when it came
out I was like five so
the song is by her favorite band Kiss
and she actually has that tattooed on
the inside of her lip for obvious
reasons the song is Beth
shout out second caller Beth I hear you
calling but I can't come home right now
me and the boys are playing
we just can't find the sound just a few
more hours and I'll be right home to you
I think I hear them calling oh Beth what
can I do beth what can I do
I know you're lonely I hope you'll be
all right because me and the boys will
be playing I never know what kiss is
talking about
it's not rocket science
[Music]
they're playing and she wants him home
way to go America way to go
Kelly was in honors classes too see you
soon